yeah peace i love peace
i'd be out of a job with peace
do we know each other
time
reality reality
[Music]
it's changeable
where you want to be
that's the question isn't it every
universe
is different each one
[Music]
slow down a little bit there's a few
people in the room that don't understand
not me i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
[Music]
i am the watcher i
observe all that transpires here
but i do not cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
i said never flies solo
ah is that some kind of catchphrase
you had me worried for a second
journey to face the unknown and ponder
the question
what if
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
just got our brand new official
trailer for marvel studios what if now
we've gotten a few teasers in the past
but this is a
full blown out trailer where we got a
lot of new scenes and
a lot of new information there's a lot
to break down so let's jump
right into it but if you're new and you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
on everything happening within the
marvel cinematic universe be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so marvel's what if series is going to
be actually pretty exciting i know i've
heard some people say that since it's
animated and doesn't really have any
impact on the mcu they're not that
interested however
the story points for what we're going to
see in this animated series
actually look really interesting and
exciting and if you may not be familiar
with what the what if series
is going to be it's essentially our
stories that we've seen before in the
marvel cinematic universe played out
differently
asking the question what if something
different
happened for example in our very first
scene here we have iron man
and killmonger now the story kind of
starts off the same
iron man is in a convoy he's taking that
classic peace sign
picture from the very first iron man and
his convoy gets attacked but
instead of him getting taken hostage he
is actually rescued
by killmonger so that's our what if
scenario for tony stark and killmonger
what if tony stark was never taken
hostage
what if killmonger saved him and what if
killmonger was good
and in wakanda as we begin the trailer
for what if
we hear the words of what appears to be
tilda swinton's the ancient one
and the voice is saying time reality
it's changeable and i must say this
seems very strategic
dropping the trailer for what if right
now right after loki episode 5 but
before
the finale because essentially all of
the different branches that are created
from the sacred timeline in loki
are essentially what-if scenarios sylvie
came into play in her
universe and ran from the tva because
the universe decided to say
what if loki was a girl arloki was
chased because the scenario of
what if loki got the tesseract and
escaped played out as well
so this was very strategically placed
because the loki series kind of sets up
what if in a way that makes it very easy
to understand
we're just tweaking a few things which
create a different reality a different
scenario in time and things play out
very very differently
for example when the voice says time
reality it's changeable we see a picture
of
the avengers and we have that classic
scene from the very first film
of them in a circle assembling where the
camera is panning around them but right
after we hear the words
changeable we notice that the characters
change
there are different avengers here and if
you look closely we can see
black panther gamora who is dressed like
her father
thanos and even has his sword that we
saw in avengers in game
we have star-lord but we know that this
star-lord
is actually t'challa as star-lord which
makes us wonder who exactly is black
panther could that be killmonger and
then we have thor on the side it looks
like he
kind of kept his place with the avengers
now we do see a scene before this where
it looks like
it's zuri walking with either t'challa
or
eric killmonger and it looks like the
scenario for this could be
what if killmonger was black panther
because we see that black panther is
indeed star-lord wakanda clearly looks
very differently here which means that
the scene in the beginning of black
panther maybe never played out maybe
killmonger's father was never killed and
maybe he actually went on to live in
wakanda
therefore allowing him to become the
black panther in a very peaceful way he
didn't have to find his way
back to wakanda he was raised there his
whole life and is actually a very good
person
that seems to be the scenario here we
then see doctor strange who does indeed
seem to be a sorcerer at this point of
time he has the eye of agamotto and the
time stone around his neck but it looks
like he gets sucked into a portal
into a different universe or reality and
we see more in him later on in the
trailer and i'll break that down
we then have yondu talking to t'challa
as star-lord and he says where you want
to be
that's the question isn't it and in this
scenario of
what if t'challa was star-lord it seems
like yondu simply abducted t'challa
instead of abducting star-lord
this could take place in the same
episode where eric killmonger is black
panther there is no t'challa there to be
black panther so eric killmonger is the
one who becomes him
becomes the new black panther while
t'challa goes on and becomes star-lord
and then a member of the avengers we
then hear a voice that says
every universe is different each one
unique
and here we see some more new footage we
see the hulk which doesn't actually look
that different it still looks like it's
bruce banner could be somebody else but
still looks like bruce banner
however we do have a scene where thor
seems to be fighting
what looks like an iron legion this
scenario right here of
what if seems to be what if thor was on
earth what if thor was a primary
guardian on earth and not
asgard now he still has the hammer he
still has the asgardian clothes on so
he's still thor the god of thunder he's
still from asgard but simply dwelling on
earth
and this could be due to the fact that
in the next scene we see
loki who is clearly the ruler of asgard
we see loki
with lady siff and the warriors 3 and an
asgardian army behind him
he is also wielding gungyer odin staff
so he is clearly in charge of asgard he
is king of asgard which is going to be
an awesome what if scenario what if loki
ruled asgard and perhaps he banished
thor to earth or perhaps he simply gave
thor the freedom to go do what he want
and thor chose to go to earth perhaps to
be with jane foster but if you notice
across from him is actually nick fury
with a bunch of shield agents behind him
so
it looks like loki lady siff and the
warriors 3 and the asgardian army
is on earth and if we know anything
about loki over time it's that he
definitely wants to rule
earth with the exception of the loki
that we have right now in the loki
series who has clearly gone through some
changes
now when we hear the voice say each one
unique we actually see
vision is the one saying each one and
then we see
howard the duck which i know a lot of
people are going to be really excited
about he's going to get to be involved
in a what if series here and then of
course we get a scene that we've seen
before
captain peggy carter flying on top of an
iron man suit that we know
is piloted by steve rogers so this what
if scenario is going to be really great
what if peggy carter was actually given
the super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers and she became captain america
we then have another shot of killmonger
fighting and it looks like him
and the wakandan warriors are fighting
some kind of android army it's very
clear that killmonger is
a great warrior of wakanda whether or
not he is the black panther or not
remains to be seen
because in another scene we actually see
queen raimonda leading the wakandan army
so perhaps she could actually be the
black panther and killmonger could
simply be her general
then we have the line from thor talking
about some people maybe not
understanding and it looks like thor
hasn't changed too much
we then have doctor strange who appears
to be incredibly powerful there's a
character
next to him that looks like it could be
the scarlet witch or perhaps even black
widow
and if you look in the background the
city wherever they're at seems to be
completely destroyed or in the process
of getting destroyed
we haven't actually seen doctor strange
yet as the source or supreme so perhaps
that's what his what if scenario is
what we do know is that he is actually
going to be in an episode with
captain peggy carter we get brand new
awesome footage of peggy carter kicking
some butt with her shield then we see
her and doctor strange interact and
doctor strange asks who are you
and she says the name's captain carter
and this also means that doctor strange
is going to be in an episode where steve
rogers is
in the iron man suit so it seems very
clear that it's not just going to be
one what-if scenario per episode it
seems like there could be a few or
perhaps that one
thing that's changed has such a drastic
effect that
it just completely changes the scenarios
of the entire universe
and we do get the big name drop
multiverse the trailer says
enter the multiverse again very fitting
considering what loki has showed us and
the fact that we're going to be going
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and spiderman no way home
we then see a glimpse of somebody inside
of the quantum realm now this is either
going to be
janet van dyne or ghost just based off
of this quick little scene right here we
have never actually seen a
scene for what if that has anybody in
the quantum realm before but i'm sure
we'll figure out more about that before
the episode releases
the watcher is then revealed we know the
watcher is going to be voiced by jeffrey
wright
kevin feige has revealed this and of
course how could you not tell with that
voice of his and in this trailer he
describes what his job is he says i am
the watcher
i observe all that transpires here but i
do not
cannot will not interfere and this is
the job
of the watcher in the marvel universe
and this is the job
of the watcher in the comics the
watchers are the oldest species known in
the universe
they observe and compile knowledge on
all aspects of the universe without
ever interfering although in some comic
stories there has been some interference
so we could see that in what if
now as he's speaking we actually see a
lot of really cool things
we see t'challa as star-lord and who his
team is
if you look all the way on the right we
can see the guy that we know as
taser face it looks like in this
scenario he's actually good we then see
kraglin next to him
of course t'challa up front as star-lord
yondu and korath the pursuer who also
looks like he's going to be good in this
what if scenario
it's definitely going to be fun to watch
this team on screen we then have a scene
of black widow
on a motorcycle and it looks like she's
trying to outrun some of ultron's
minions
and then from here we have a lot of
really quick scenes where if you blink
you'll miss what's happening
we have the what if zombie episode where
we see zombie captain america
zombie iron man and if you look behind
him we could see ebony maw and coal
obsidian so perhaps zombie iron man and
zombie captain america could be the
product of the children of thanos we
then appear to have a scene from the
very first thor film where thor is in
the rain trying to pick up his hammer
and hawkeye is looking at him
it's been said that we're going to be
getting a party thor and what if
perhaps party thor happens when thor
can't lift the hammer perhaps that goes
a very different way
in what if we then have an explosion
that is seemingly happening
in wakanda we see a little baby shuri
walk out the dora milaje behind her and
it looks like it's actually
pepper behind her fighting as well which
makes sense because if iron man is going
to be saved by killmonger and taken back
to wakanda
it would make sense that pepper would go
to wakanda and it looks like they're
going to be helping them fight
we then have the return of kurt
russell's ego but if you look in the
background behind him it looks to be
some type of restaurant with the chairs
on top of the tables so perhaps in this
what-if scenario he goes and he searches
for star-lord instead of waiting for him
to come to him
and perhaps he finds him on earth we
then have doctor strange looking like he
could be in the hell dimension
and right after that we actually do see
peggy carter or captain carter
fighting schuma gorith and in the scene
right after it looks like the ancient
one is actually fighting doctor strange
perhaps the ancient one could actually
be
evil in this what-if scenario and she is
the one who released schumachureth
because it's very clear
that doctor strange and captain carter
are going to be fighting together we
then have what looks to be the scarlet
witch being attacked by the dora melange
which seems a bit odd but perhaps she is
the threat to wakanda
but then again these two scenes could be
unrelated and they could simply
be trying to make them look related then
again super quickly we have drax with
t'challa as star-lord
black widow throwing a shield killmonger
leading the wakandan army we then go
back to loki and his asgardian army and
we see him using the casket of ancient
winters
and if you look in the background you
can actually see the destroyer is there
as well
we also seemingly see ultron's army and
vision actually taken the mind stone out
of his
own head now we don't see ultron in this
trailer but marvel did release an
official poster today and it looks like
ultron is going to collect all of the
infinity stones or at least he's going
to try
as you can see in this photo on his
chest he has at least
four infinity stones it also looks like
this
could be vision as ultron he was
supposed to be
ultron so perhaps this what if scenario
is what if vision did become ultron we
then have more of schumagorth the hulk
and a very disturbing
image of just a head here thor throwing
his hammer
and then an awesome scene of t'challa as
star-lord
with yondu backing him up and the final
scene actually looks like
yondu and star-lord t'challa star-lord
fighting the collector now there was a
spider-man in this and some people are
claiming that this kind of looks like
andrew garfield spider-man
and that is possible but although we
didn't see much of spider-man in this
trailer again
in the poster that marvel released we
actually see spider-man
wearing doctor strange's cloak so it
looks like our spider-man what-if
scenario is going to be
sort of a spider supreme if you will and
that's it for this
awesome new official marvel's what if
trailer
be sure to let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof